[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta
Slomka guten Abend also wenn wir den
Agrardiesel jetzt doch noch länger
subventionieren müssen dann nehmen wir
beim me Schutz ein bisschen was weg und
an der fischereikomponente können wir
auch noch etwas schrauben so kleinteilig
kann es durchaus zugehen wenn der
Bundeshaushalt den letzten Schliff
bekommt das mit Zahlen jongliert wird
und manchmal auch ein bisschen nach
Kochrezept eine Prise hier eine Prise da
ist normal doch bei der Erstellung
dieses Haushalts stand die Küche ja
lichterlo in Flammen zeitweise schien
nicht ausgeschlossen dass die
Ampelkoalition daran
zerbricht das erklärt wohl auch die
Erleichterung die den finanzpolitikern
heute anzusehen war als sie die
Endfassung präsentierten aus Berlin
Daniel
tzen es liegt also wieder Schnee jetzt
da er steht der Haushalt ähnlich wie
damals als man mit den Beratungen begann
die Stimmung heute betont harmonisch bei
den Haushältern der Ampel nach dem
gestrigen Schlussakt man blicke zurück
auf immer fare vertrauensvolle und auf
freundschaftliche Verhandlungen in fair
Atmosphäre deswegen will ich im Anfang
mich auch noch mal einfach bedanken die
demonstrative Einigkeit zum Abschluss
sie steht in krassem Gegensatz zur
Genese des Haushalts die vergangenen
Winter mit diesem Briefwechsel beginnt
man werde die haushaltseckwerte nicht
akzeptieren schrieb Wirtschaftsminister
habck im Namen der Grünen damals an
Finanzminister Lindner der antwortete
überrascht und gereizt es wäre für die
Berechenbarkeit des Handelns der
Bundesregierung insgesamt ratsam wenn
die sie ihre eigenen Beschlüsse achtet
es folgt ein Drama in mehreren Akten
nachdem Familienministerin Paus ihre
Kindergrundsicherung nicht durchkriegt
blockiert sie ein Entlastungspaket für
Unternehmen als man sich endlich zu
einer Einigung durchringt das
schockurteil aus Karlsruhe das die
gesamte Finanzplanung der Ampel
impludieren lässt in zehn Sitzungen
quält man sich zu einem Kompromiss der
unter anderem eine höhere CO2 Abgabe
vorsieht und vor allem Bauern belastet
die daraufhin lautstark protestieren
ihnen gibt die Ampel auch nun nicht
weiter nach da Anfang der Woche
plötzlich gut 6 Milliarden Euro mehr da
sind übrig vom vorjahresabschluss
erübrigt hat sich dadurch das Aussetzen
der Schuldenbremse und der Streit
darüber
vorerst Teil der politischen Einigung
ist eben auch wenn sich wesentliche
Teile in der nächsten Zeit verändern
wenn es wesentliche Veränderung gibt
wenn wir die Ukraine vielleicht noch
stärker unterstützen müssen dass wir
dann darüber wieder diskutieren dass da
Änderungs und Reformbedarf ist das ist
auch wissenschaftlich eigentlich
weitgehend geteilt dass man dort zu
einer treffsicheren Schuldenbremse
kommen muss aber jetzt damit Sie auch
einmal sehen dass wir nicht immer der
gleichen Meinung sind nicht ne nein ich
weise nur gerne noch mal darauf hin die
Schuldenbremse ist erkennbar keine
Investitionsbremse aus unserer Sicht
Konflikt vertagt also komplett einig ist
man sich dann wieder in der Kritik an
der Union die sich einer konstruktiven
Beratung gestern verweigert habe die
Union weiß den Vorwurf energisch zurück
moniert in einem Zitat chaotischen
Verfahren mit mehr als 1000
Änderungsanträgen geflutet worden zu
sein vor allem aber sehe man die
finanzpolitische Kernaufgabe weiter
ungelöst die Ampel ist nach wie vor
nicht bereit über ihre eigenen Projekte
überhaupt mal nachzudenken sie spart
nicht oder nur wenig dazu passe dass die
Ampel die erst jüngst angekündigen
bürgergeldkürzung für sogenannte
Totalverweigerer mit dem
Haushaltsbeschluss nun auf z Jahre
grenzt zeitlich begrenzen wolle man
übrigens trotz aller Harmonie zum
Abschluss künftig auch wieder die
Beratungen zum
Haushalt das wollen wir noch etwas
vertiefen mit einem Ökonomen mit
professor Michael Hüther Direktor des
Instituts der deutschen Wirtschaft guten
Abend Herr Professor Hüter schönen guten
Abend Frau slomker Politiker und
Ökonomen sagen ja auch gerne der
Haushalt das sei das schicksalsbuch der
Nation wenn Sie sich jetzt dieses
schicksalsbuch angucken wie würden unser
Schicksal umschreiben ist eine
Ansammlung von kleinen Kurzgeschichten
die uns da angeboten werden denn die
Dramatik der letzten Wochen äh war ja
gar nicht so nötig die Unterdeckung im
Haushalt war schon im Haushaltsentwurf
vom Sommer erkennbar und das was jetzt
zusammengefflegt werden musste in
wenigen Wochen war eigentlich wesentlich
unabhängig von dem
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil was alle jetzt
anführen das betraf den Klima- und
transformationsfond den Bundeshaushalt
aber nur in kleinere Maße mit den 2,7
Milliarden äh Aufbauhilfe für
rheinlandfalz und nordrehein-westfahen
nach der Flut aber ansonsten sind das
originäre Schwierigkeiten die der
Bundesfinanzminister oder die
Bundesregierung haben den Haushalt
angemessen zu gestalten na diesen
originären Schwierigkeiten ist
sicherlich auch eine dass man eben sehr
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen davon hat
was was man will und was man auf keinen
Fall machen darf also z.B auf gar keinen
Fall die Schuldenbremse lockern auf gar
keinen Fall neue Steuern
Steuern erhöhen sagt der
Bundesfinanzminister da wird's natürlich
irgendwie schwierig so Ihre Wünsche
haben ja es wird schwierig wenn man
gleichzeitig auch den größten
Ausgabenblock nämlich die sozialausgabe
mit über 50% ja beachtlicher Anteil wie
jeder man erkennen kann des
Bundeshaushalts auch für unveränderbar
hält und dann kommt viel Kleinkram
zustande und dann wirbelt man Dinge auf
die Leute ärgern die nicht verstehen
warum sie dann gerade betroffen sind
obwohl es in der Sache wie
beispielsweise bei den agrar
dieselsubventionen und bei den
Steuersubventionen KFZ für die Landwirte
ja durchaus begründbar ist das sind
Relikte aus einer anderen Zeit das kann
man aber anders machen das kann man auch
besser vorbereiten jetzt hat man viel
Aufruhr aber am Ende wenig Ertrag denn
für das nächste Jahr und für die Jahre
danach ist noch nichts gelöst
die Themen die jetzt hier auf dem Tisch
liegen helfen in diesem Jahr aber sie
sind nicht nachhaltig und sie bringen
den Haushalt nicht dauerhaft in eine
bessere Spur was befürchten sie denn
dann fürs nächste Jahr bzw für 2025
Klammer auf mutmaßlich ein
bundestagswahljah falls es nicht schon
vorher irgendwie auseinanderbricht
Klammer zu was erwarten sie denn wo
dannn da die größten Brocken und
Schwierigkeiten die jetzt sozusagen
übertüncht werden auf die Haushälter
zukommen nun schon im Haushaltsentwurf
im Sommer wurde mitgeteilt dass für 25 5
Milliarden fehlen noch nicht wirklich im
Blick sind das wird sich jetzt weiter
ausweiten denn viele der Maßnahmen die
jetzt genannt sind greifen gerade mal in
diesem Jahr das heißt für nächstes Jahr
wird man aufgrund der Dynamik der
Ausgaben und der schwachen Konjunktur
auf der anderen Seite wir sehen ja
letztes Jahr eine Schrumpfung wir
erwarten für dieses Jahr eine
Schrumpfung und und auch für 25 wird das
nicht prächtig werden dass die
Steuereinnahmen eher schwächer ausfallen
das heißt der Druck nimmt zu dann kann
man sagen gut die konjunkturkomponente
fängt einiges auf aber die großen
investitionsthemen die man adressieren
will die wird man nicht bewältigen
können da wären sie dafür dass man an
der Schuldenbremse vielleicht doch noch
mal etwas rüttelt oder etwas ändert na
ich wäre dafür dass man die
Investitionen in einem anders
aufgestellten Haushalt außerhalb des
Bundeshaushalts organisiert das ist ein
großes Thema das ist auch über längere
period als 12 Monate zu organisieren
aber wir haben auch in diesem Haushalt
selbst große Herausforderungen denn die
Bundeswehr beispielsweise soll ja
nachhaltig mit mindestens 2% am brutto
Inlandsprodukt finanziert werden im
Finanzplan ist schon eine Unterdeckung
2026 von 10 Milliarden 2027 von 40
Milliarden drin wer das lösen will muss
doch jetzt schon die Schneisen schlagen
damit diese Verpflichtungen im Bereich
der NATO die ja uns ja auch alle
augenfällig sind dass wir in der anderen
Welt sind dass diese auch möglich werden
nichts davon ist erkennbar und insofern
ist das hat noch nichts stattgefunden an
repriorisierung der Aufgaben an neue
Definition der Schwerpunkte und da muss
man insgesamt RAM das ist keine Sache
für Nacht und nebelaktionen sondern für
eine nachhaltige strategische
Aufstellung der Politik sagt der
Direktor des Instituts der deutschen
Wirtschaft Herr Hüter danke für das
Gespräch sehr
gerne zu den finanzpolitischen Themen
über die in der Ampel monatelang
gestritten wurde gehörten auch die
Subventionen für Unternehmen die viel
Energie verbrauchen und dementsprechend
die hohen Strompreise hart Z spüren
bekommen auch da ging es letztlich um
ökonomische Glaubensfragen soll der
Staat für besonders betroffene
Unternehmen den Strompreis senken das
wollte Wirtschaftsminister habbeck oder
hilft man allen Unternehmen durch eine
Senkung der Stromsteuer dafür plädierte
Finanzminister Lindner am Ende ist es
eine Mischung geworden bei der einige
hundert Konzerne weiterhin zusätzlich
noch entlast werden diese Lösung bekam
aus der Wirtschaft auch durchaus Lob
aber es nimmt nicht allen die Sorgen wie
Cornelia schimens
berichtet bis zu
1800° Celsius braucht es um aus Schrott
Stahl zu fertigen bei veralpi im
sächsischen Rieser passiert das im
elektrolichtbogenofen ein Verfahren das
enorm viel Energie Frist die hohen
Strompreise treiben Uwe reinike um der
Werksleiter schaut mit Sorge ins neue
Jahr beklagt dass mittelständige
Unternehmen wie seines von Berlin aus
nicht gesehen
würden für die großen Konzerne wird viel
Geld gegeben für ihren Weg der
Transformation und den Mittelstand also
die elektrostahrute in Deutschland die
immerhin 30% der stahlmenge ausmachen
die in Deutschland produziert wird die
vergisst man vergessen bei
subventionierten Strompreisen und bei
Förderprogrammen für mehr grünen Strom
so Reineke stattdessen steigen die
Preise für Energie noch weiter da der
Bundeszuschuss für die Netzentgelte in
Höhe von 5,5 Milliarden Euro gestrichen
wurde wegen des haushaltsloches für
veralpi bedeutet das Mehrkosten von 10
Millionen Euro im Jahr das macht sich
schon sehr deutlich bemerkbar das können
bis zu 20 € preisteurung sein pro
Megawattstunde und das wird letztendlich
auch unsere Tonne Stahl um 10 bis 11 €
verteuern Wirtschaftsexperten wie
Joachim rangnz gehen trzdem davon aus
dass sich die Konjunktur im Laufe des
Jahres leicht erholen wird allerdings
nicht in allen Branchen Stahl Glas
Papier sind eben die Zweige die halt
eher na ja nicht so besonders gut laufen
werden und na ja man muss ja davon
ausgehen dass S Energiepreise dauerhaft
relativ hoch bleiben also das heißt da
ist eine enorme Anpassungsdruck da
Anpassungsdruck den sie auch bei
sachsenglas in Kemnitz spüren hier
fertigen Sie Sicherheitsglas für
Einkaufszentren Brüstungen Fassaden das
Glas wird thermisch veredelt das kostet
jede Menge Strom deshalb hat die Firma
schon vor Jahren ein
energiemanagementystem eingeführt
grundsätzlich ist es so dass wir
natürlich ein Sinn dafür haben für
Umweltschutz und für alternative
Energien gar keine Frage aber das darf
natürlich nicht so sein dass wir am Ende
durch die hohen Stromkosten oder die
hohen Preise die wir haben dort nicht
mehr wettbewerbsfähig sind nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig gegenüber den
Nachbarländern zudem in Polen und
Tschechien niedrigere Löhne gezahlt
werden die schwächelnde Baubranche setzt
sachsenglas ebenso zu der Blick zu
Beginn des Jahres deshalb nur verhalten
optimistisch wird letztendlich ein Kampf
am Markt stattfinden so ein
Verdrängungswettbewerb stattfinden und
den müssen wir uns stellen das Ziel die
nächsten zwei Jahre zu überstehen bis
die Krise vorbei
ist Hoh Energiepreise mau Konjunkturlage
und
Personalmangel es gibt ja so einiges
worüber worüber man sich in den
Unternehmen sorgen macht vor diesem
Hintergrund äußerten sich Vertreter der
Wirtschaft zuletzt auch ungewöhnlich
politisch angesichts der hohen
umfrageewwerte der AFD warnten sie dass
der Eindruck Deutschland werde zunehmend
ausländerfeindlicher und rassistischer
wirtschaftliche Folgen habe das schrecke
auch Zuwanderer ab die man brauche die
Bundesregierung will gesetzlich
gegensteuern einerseits soll zwar
schneller abgeschoben werden
andererseits sollen Einbürgerungen und
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaften
erleichtert werden Karl Hinterleitner
mit den
Einzelheiten es geht um die Frage wer
ist Deutscher wer wird Staatsbürger und
unter welchen Bedingungen die
bundesinnenministerin hatte heute morgen
für das neue Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht
geworben es zeige Migranten dass sie
willkommen sind
angebte deswegen werbe ich noch mal
angesichts der aktuellen Lage wo
von ganz rechts außen Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund gerade
wirklich schlimm ausgegrenzt werden noch
mal darum dass man dieses
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht wirklich als
Chance auch ansieht die wesentlichen
Punkte Einbürgerung soll statt schon
nach 5 Jahren möglich sein bei
besonderer Integrationsleistung schon
nach 3 Jahren die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft ist in Zukunft
grundsätzlich für alle möglich im
Bundestag gab es dazu heute eine oft
emotionale Debatte einige Abgeordnete
berührt das neue Gesetz sehr persönlich
für mich hat sich das Jahr ind dem ich
18 wurde fest in meiner Erinnerung
verankert das lag allerdings weniger an
meinem Geburtstag sondern viel mehr
daran dass ich mit 18 endlich
eingebürgert wurde nachdem ich bereits
15 JRE in Deutschland gelebt hatte die
FDP stellte klar das Gesetz erleichtert
viele Einbürgerungen verhindert aber
auch andere z.B wenn jemand durch
Fremdenfeindlichkeit Rassismus oder
Antisemitismus aufgefallen ist wer
Deutscher werden will muss ich
ausdrücklich und dezidiert explizit zur
freiheitlich demokratischen Grundordnung
bekennen die Union spricht sich gegen
das neue Gesetz aus die Einbürgerung
werde damit zu leicht gemacht die
Fristen seien zu kurz weil wir den Pass
auf Ewigkeit verleihen gilt der gute
alte deutsche Satz drum prüfe wer sich
ewig bindet und je kürzer die Fristen
sind mit fünf oder gar 3 Jahren kann
noch keine Verwurzlung in unserem Land
stattgefunden haben die AFD lehnt das
Gesetz und jede Erleichterung von
Einbürgerungen ganz grundsätzlich ab die
stolze Staatsbürgerschaft soll
verramscht werden an quasi alle die sich
F bis Z D Jahre in Deutschland auf
gehalten haben am frühen Nachmittag
stimmte der Bundestag ab und
verabschiedete das Gesetz mit deutlicher
Mehrheit jetzt muss noch der Bundesrat
zustimmen mehr Hintergründe und
Erklärungen zum Thema Staatsrecht und
Einbürgerungen finden Sie bei uns online
auf ZDF
heute am Wochenende wird es weiter
zahlreiche Demonstrationen gegen
Rassismus und Rechtsextremismus geben
Sowi schon in den letzten Tagen und auch
heute Heinz ja heute gab es
Demonstrationen in mehreren Städten eine
besonders große in Hamburg nach
unterschiedlichen Angaben beteiligten
sich zwischen 50.000 und 80.000 Menschen
weil der antrang so groß war wurde die
Demonstration schließlich von den
Organisatoren vorzeitig
beendet Bundeskanzler Scholz begrüßte in
seiner wöchentlichen Videobotschaft die
Demonstrationen und verurteilte
Rechtsextremismus der
aerarls geht in diesem Jahr an den
Präsidenten der Europäischen
rabbinerkonferenz Pinchas Goldschmidt
und an die jüdischen Gemeinschaften in
Europa die Jury würdigte in ihrer
Begründung unter anderem Goldschmidts
Einsatz für die Verständigung zwischen
den Religionen weiter hieß es das
karlspreisdirektorium will mit dieser
Auszeichnung das Signal setzen dass
jüdisches Leben selbstverständlich zu
Europa gehört und in Europa kein Platz
für Antisemitismus sein
darf china hat die militant
islamistische husim Miliz dazu
aufgerufen ihre Angriffe auf
Handelsschiffe im Roten Meer zu stoppen
eine Sprecherin des Handelsministeriums
betonte die Bedeutung der Route für den
Ablauf der globalen Produktions und
Lieferketten die von Iran unterstützte
huimiliz hat China und Russland sichere
Durchfahrt im Roten Meer zugesagt da die
beiden Länder als strategische Partner
Irans
gelten die EU geht mit Sanktionen gegen
Mitglieder und Unterstützer der Hamas
und des palästinensischen islamistischen
islamischen dihad vor heute wurden
Strafmaßnahmen zunächst gegen sechs
Personen verhängt darunter im Sudan und
in Algerien ansässige Geldgeber und
Männer im Libanon die an Geldgeschäften
zugunsten der Hammers beteiligt sein
sollen die Sanktionen bedeuten unter
anderem dass EU-weit Vermögenswerte der
Betroffenen eingefroren werden müssen
und sie auch nicht mehr in die EU
einreisen dürfen
eine unbemannte japanische Sonde ist
heute auf dem Mond gelandet allerdings
gibt es Probleme mit der Stromversorgung
so die japanische Raumfahrtagentur die
Solarzellen funktionieren offenbar nicht
das Mini Raumschiff Slim arbeitet
derzeit noch mit Batteriestrom es soll
auf dem Mond Gesteine untersuchen und
nach Wasser forschen erfolgreiche
Mondlandungen sind bisher nur den USA
der Sowjetunion China und Indien
gelungen angesichts der der Größe und
Wucht des ukrainekrieges konnte der
Krieg zwischen Aserbeidschan und
Armenien nicht die gleiche
Aufmerksamkeit der Europäer auf sich
ziehen was ja vielleicht auch Kalkül war
im Schatten eines anderen großkrieges
einen Feldzug durchzuziehen den man sich
schon lange auf die Fahnen geschrieben
hat vier Monate ist es her dass
Aserbeidschan in
Bergkarabach Fakten geschaffen hat
völkerrechtlich gehörte die Region auch
zu aser
wurde aber mehrheitlich von Armenier
bewohnt das friedlich zu lösen ist über
Jahrzehnte nicht
gelungen Nina Niebergall ist für uns
nach Armenien gereist um zu erfahren wie
es den Vertriebenen seitdem ergangen
ist Marine gabrielian konnte nur diesen
Ofen aus Bergkarabach retten er sichert
das Überleben der Familie sie backt
typisch armenische Pfannkuchen verdient
damit als einzige in der Familie ein
wenig Geld in berkarabach hatte sie
einen eigenen Laden ein eigenes Haus
hier fühlt sie sich wie eine
Fremde es ist schwer für uns morgens
aufzuwachen und nicht zu Hause zu sein
nicht in unserem Garten hier haben wir
keine Nachbarn keine Verwandten in der
Nähe wir sind überall verstreut leben
weit voneinander
entfernt die Söhne helfen ihr Mann kann
nicht arbeiten weil er eine Behinderung
hat ihr Bruder ist in einem der
Bergkarabach Kriege
gestorben das ist das
Schlimmste dass wir die Gräber meiner
Verwandten zurücklassen
mussten vor allem dass ich das Grab
meines Bruders nicht mehr besuchen
kann die meisten Flüchtlinge aus
berkarabach sind in den Armen Vororten
der Hauptstadt Erwan untergekommen die
Regierung unterstützt sie zwar
finanziell doch viele finden keine Jobs
keine eigene
Wohnung September vergangenes Jahr gut
100000 Armenier mussten aus Bergkarabach
fliehen praktisch die gesamte
Bevölkerung Aserbeidschan schafft
drastische
Fakten viele Armenier haben Angst dass
Aserbaidschan sich nicht mit
Bergkarabach zufrieden gibt sondern bald
das Kernland angreift denn auch das
sieht Aserbaidschans autokratische
Herrscher iljam aliev als sein Einfluss
Gebiet leider wurde Erwan 1918 an
Armenien übergeben ohne Grund eran war
historisch aerbeidschanisch das
aserbeidschanische Volk hat dort
jahrhundertelang
gelebt Marine hält den Friedensprozess
zwischen den beiden Staaten deshalb für
eine Fars sie traut dem Feind
nicht mit Aserbeidschan kann es keine
Friedensverträge geben heute
unterzeichnen Sie eine Vereinbarung
morgen haben wir Tote
sie diktieren also ihre eigene Agenda
ohne irgendwelche Verträge
einzuhalten irgendwann wollen sie nach
Bergkarabach zurückkehren Marine und
ihre Familie daran dass es friedlich
gelingen wird glauben Sie nicht notfalls
würden sie einen weiteren Krieg in Kauf
nehmen und dann gehen wir noch zurück
nach Deutschland mitck auf die
wirtcha Industrie dort hat sich das
Geschäftsklima nach neuen Daten des io
Instituts im Dezember verschlechtert
sieer mein jetzt woran liegt welche
Schwierigkeiten sieht die Branche also
es gibt gleich eine ganze Reihe an
Hörden mit denen die Branche
konfrontiert wird der chemierise BSF hat
heute sowohl die Markterwartungen als
auch die eigenen Ziele verfehlt nach
zahlreichen Jahren in denen BSF gutes
Geld verdient hat gab es vergangenes
Jahr beim operativen Gewinn vor
Sondereinflüssen einen Einbruch um 45%
auf 3 ,8 Milliarden Euro die Gründe
hierfür sind unter anderem die generelle
Flaute der gesamten Chemiebranche
aufgrund einer schwachen Nachfrage hohen
Energiekosten und einem mäßigen
Auslandsgeschäft allen voran in China
erst kürzlich kündigte branenriese Bayer
ein Stellenabbau an heute nun die
mauenzahlen der BASF insgesamt
beschäftigt die Chemieindustrie in
Deutschland rund eine halbe Million
Menschen und die Stimmung hat sich
deutlich eingetrübt das zeigen die
Zahlen des ifo Geschäftsklimaindex zwar
ist die Tal laut des Münchner Instituts
wohl erreicht aber der Aufwärtstrend in
der Chemiebranche noch nicht in Sicht
wegen hoher Energiepreise planten
Unternehmen die Produktion ins Ausland
zu verlagern die Stimmung in der
Chemiebranche ist in bestimmten
Bereichen sogar so schlecht wie zuletzt
in Zeiten der Finanzkrise in den Jahren
2008 und 2009 ja auch die Stimmung der
Anleger war schon einmal besser der DAX
geht mit einem Minus ins Wochenende am
Ende ein standand von
16555 Punkten es ist die Ungewissheit
über künftige Zinssenkungen welche die
Investoren derzeit bremst Sina meinitz
vielen
Dank die Deutsche Bahn hat die
Gewerkschaft deutscher Lokomotivführer
aufgefordert an den Verhandlungstisch
zurückzukehren und dazu ein Angebot
vorgelegt es sieht stufenweise
Lohnerhöhungen vor sowie für Lockführer
und Zugpersonal eine Möglichkeit zu
kürzerer Wochenarbeitszeit bei gleichem
Gehalt die GDL will das Angebot nun
prüfen der Krankenstand am Arbeitsplatz
ist das zweite Jahr infolge auf einem
Rekordhoch ergab eine Auswertung eigener
Versicherten Daten der Krankenkasse DAK
demnach waren Beschäftigte 2023 im
Schnitt 20 Tage krank geschrieben die
meisten Fehltage gingen auf
Erkältungskrankheiten zurück gefolgt von
Krankheiten des
muskelskelettsystems und psychischen
Diagnosen bei der Handball EM hatte die
deutsche Mannschaft heute Pause nach dem
Sieg gestern gegen Island und vor dem
Spiel morgen gegen Österreich aber es
gab heute in Hamburg die Partie
Weltmeister gegen Europameister Dänemark
gegen Schweden nach rund 26 Minuten
konnten sich die Dänen etwas absetzen
und hatten einen vier Torevorsprung der
sich aber bis zur Pause auf zwei
verringerte da stand es dann 17 Z
15 in der zweiten Halbzeit blieb es eine
knappe Partie die Dänen lagen bis zum
Ende vorn und holten sich den Sieg mit
28:
27 wenn eine Trauerfeier sehr gelungen
war kann am jaah der Gedanke kommen
schade dass er oder sie das nicht
erleben konnte die Reden die Musik die
Atmosphäre und wer alles da war was ja
umso mehr dafür spricht dass man
Menschen zu Lebzeiten häufiger sagt wie
liebenswert sie sind und dass man schöne
feste miteinander feiert und
Erinnerungen teilt dass die trau
für Franz Beckenbauer den Kaiser in der
Allianzarena stattfand entspricht der
Größe seiner Biografie und irgendwie
passte es zu ihm dass es trotz dieser
riesigen Kulisse Momente gab die sich
familiär anfüllten Stefan le war
dabei und plötzlich ist da dieser Moment
ohne Regie ganz eplant
spontan
einm ckenbauer noch mal
vorbeizehen und das ganze Stadion erhebt
sich Tränen fließen der Applaus will
nicht enden
minutenlang es ist der emotionale
Höhepunkt eines innigen eines
würdevollen eines persönlichen Abschieds
vom Kaiser lieber
Franz jetzt bist du 12 Tage
tot und um ehrlich zu sein du fehlst mir
sehr in
Frieden ruhe in Frieden einem Frieden
den du leider in den letzten Jahren
nicht in der Form genießen konntest wie
Du es verdient hast vielen
Dank es ist ein Jahrhundert Leben das in
der Allianzarena noch mal bestaunt wird
der Beifall gilt dem Fußballer die
Tränen dem Menschen franzbeckenbauer auf
der Tribüne Spiegel sich die vielen
Stationen und Rollen Beckenbauers sp
Trainer Funktionär Diplomat Botschafter
eines ganzen
Landes ich bin wirklich viel durch die
Welt gereist und wohin ich immer kam auf
allen Kontinenten kannte und kennt man
Franz
Beckenbauer als diplomatisches
Naturtalent wurde er zum beliebtesten
Botschafter unseres
Landes ich werde mit dir gehen singor J
dieier
den Ton undärm die Herzen der
über freundegen Rosen im Mittelkreis
nieder der heute nur aus einem
besteht sein Spruch war immer geht raus
und spielt
Fußball lasst uns alle so weitermachen
lass uns rausgehen und spielen in seinem
Sinne im Sinne von
frzen der FC Bayern auf alle Fälle wir
im
bleben und das auf
ewig ein Mann der mit seinem Glück so
viele andere glücklich machte doch auch
die einsamen letzten Jahre des Franz
Beckenbauer nach den Vorwürfen rund um
die WM 2006 klingen heute an ein von
Schatten reden das Licht von Franz
Beckenbauer strahlt hell und prall und
weit über das ganze
hinaus es ist viel vom Licht die Rede
heute von Heimat und Freiheit die
Strahlkraft des Franz Beckenbauer wird
bleiben München hat ihm heute ein
Denkmal
gesetzt das war's von uns im heute
journal an diesem Freitagabend und gegen
0:20 Uhr meldet sich dann Christopher
wehmann mit unserem heute journal Update
und gleich geht's erstmal weiter mit
einer heutehow spezial noch
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Daten von der
NASA und Noah sind ausgewertet und es
ist das wärmste Jahr seit
Aufzeichnungsbeginn weltweit gesehen das
vergangene Jahr es gab ja etliche
Extremwetterereignisse und das Jahr
2024 könnte sogar noch wärmer werden
wobei das das Jahr 2023 hier schon an
der 1,5° Marke kratzt einige Datensätze
zeigen sogar dass es überschritten wurde
schauen wir auf das aktuelle Wetter und
das Extremwetter der letzten Tage ja das
brachte einiges an Eis und Schnee und
diese luftmaßengrenze war bis Frankreich
zu spüren sie sehen es hier in weiß und
was sich da drüber bewegt das sind die
Wolken auus dem gab es heute viel
Sonnenschein in der Nacht gibt's ganz im
Norden viele Wolken Regen und Schnee und
dazum kräftigen Westwind ansonsten kllar
es auf es bildet sich Nebel und es wird
knackig kalt mit Temperaturen bis -18°
an den Alpen hier also strenger Frost
-15 im Westen 1 bis 3° ganz im Norden
Deutschlands morgen dann viel Sonne vor
allem nach Süden hin in der Mitte
teilweise auch nach Osten hin ganz im
Norden ist es dicht bewirkt aber in
einigen Tälern bleibt es den ganzen Tag
dicht mit Nebel und dann steigen die
Temperaturen nicht über die 0° Marke
also Dauerfrost z.B hier im wen mit -3°
6° plus im Norden ja am Sonntag bleibt
es noch relativ ruhig und am Montag
erreicht uns ein Sturmtief einen schönen
Abend